SO OSWALD IS GREAT
FOR UNIVERSAL.
WALT GOES TO CHARLES MINTZ
AND HE SAYS,
LISTEN, WE ARE [BLEEP]
KILLING IT,
TIME FOR YOU TO PAY US
SOME MORE MONEY.
AND MINTZ, MINTZ LOOKS AT HIM
AND HE LAUGHS.
[laughs]
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU LESS MONEY.
AND MINTZ GOES, I HAVE SIGNED
ALL OF YOUR ANIMATORS,
AND I OWN OSWALD, HE'S MINE.
WALT DISNEY VOWED FROM THAT DAY,
NOT ONLY WILL I EVER NOT OWN
ANY CHARACTER I CREATE,
I WILL NEVER NOT OWN THEM.
THEY-THE [laughs]
I THINK.
HE SAID TO UB,
UB, YOU WITH ME?
AND UB, YET AGAIN,
LEFT WITH WALT DISNEY,
AND UB SAID TO HIM,
WHAT ARE WE DOING WALT?
AND WALT'S LIKE, WE NEED A
CHARACTER, UB, WHAT DO YOU GOT?
WHAT ABOUT A HORSE?
NOPE.
WHAT ABOUT A DOG?
[sighs]
WHAT ABOUT A CAT?
NO, MAN,
WE GOT ENOUGH CATS.
WE GOT FELIX THE CAT,
THERE'S A LOT OF CATS OUT THERE.
WHAT ELSE YOU GOT?
WHAT ABOUT A MOUSE?
WALT'S LIKE, YEAH,
LET'S DO THAT.
BUT WHAT HAPPENED NEXT
WAS ALL UB IWERKS, OKAY?
SO UB LOCKED HIMSELF
IN THE STUDIO,
AND HE CHURNS OUT 600 TO 700
FRAMES A DAY, UNHEARD OF.
HE DID TWO MONTHS OF ANIMATION
IN TWO WEEKS,
AND HE CREATED A CHARACTER,
MICKEY MOUSE.
HE SAT DOWN AND DREW
THAT CARTOON PLAIN CRAZY,
WALT LOVES IT,
BUT HE GOES YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE NEED SOMETHING BIGGER,
AND UB WAS LIKE,
BUT WHAT IF WE COULD
SYNC SOUND TO IT?
WHAT IF WE DID OUR NEXT CARTOON
WHERE WE COULD SEE
THE ACTION HAPPENING IN THE TIME
WITH THE MUSIC,
AND WALT WAS LIKE YEAH,
LET'S DO SYNC SOUND.
SO STEAMBAY--SO STEAM MILL--
SO STEAMBOAT WILLIE COMES OUT
AND IT BLOWS AUDIENCES AWAY.
THEY WENT,
I CAN SEE THAT MOUSE WHISTLING.
I CAN HEAR THE MOUSE WHISTLING,
OH MY GOD,
THIS MOUSE IS WHISTLING ALONG
WITH WHAT HIS MOUTH IS DOING.
THERE'S [bleep] SYNC SOUND.
THERE WERE STANDING OVATIONS.
MICKEY MOUSE BECAME
AN ICON OVERNIGHT.
HE WAS REFERENCED
IN MOVIES AND SONGS,
AND IT CREATES DISNEY.
LIKE THIS EM--EMBELLISHES
THEIR MICE TO EVERYBODY.
THEY KNOW THAT THIS IS LIKE
THE GAME HAS CHANGED.
WITH THE ADDED PRESSURES
OF MICKEY DOING REALLY WELL,